in our other videos
we talked about the basics of
fine-tuning a language model with
tensorflow and as always when i refer to
videos i'll link them below
still can we do better
so here's the code from our model fine
tuning video and while it works we could
definitely tweak a couple of things
by far the most important thing is the
learning rate in this video we'll talk
about how to change it which will make
your training much more consistently
successful
in fact
really there are two things we want to
change about the default learning rate
for adam
so the first thing we want to change is
that it's way too high for our models by
default atom uses a learning rate of 10
to the minus 3 1e minus 3 and that's
very high for training transformer
models we're going to start at 5 by 10
to the minus 5 5 e minus 5 which is 20
times lower than the default
and secondly we don't just want a
constant learning rate we can get even
better performance if we decay the
learning rate down to a tiny value or
even to zero over the course of training
so that's what this this thing here this
polynomial decay schedule is doing
so i'll show you what that decay looks
like in a second but first we need to
tell the scheduler how long training is
going to be so that it decays at the
right speed and that's what this code
here is doing
we're computing how many mini batches
the model is going to see over its
entire training run which is the length
of the training set
and then we multiply that by the number
of epochs to get the total number of
batches across the whole training run
once we know how many training steps
we're taking we just pass all of that
information to the scheduler and are
ready to go
so what does the polynomial decay
schedule actually look like
well
it looks like this it starts at 5e minus
5 which means 5
times 10 to the minus 5
and then it decays down at a constant
rate until it hits zero right at the
very end of training so i can hold on i
can already hear you yelling at your
monitor though and yes i know this is
actually constant or linear decay and i
know the name is polynomial and you're
feeling cheated that you you know you
were promised a polynomial and you
haven't gotten it so calm down though
it's okay
because of course linear functions are
just first order special cases of the
general polynomial functions
and if you tweak the options uh to this
class you can get a truly polynomial a
higher order decay schedule but
this linear schedule will work fine for
us for now we don't actually need all
those uh
fancy tweaks and fancy gadgets
so
coming back how do we actually use this
learning rate schedule once we've
created it so it's simple we just pass
it to adam
so the first time when we compiled the
model we just passed the string adam to
get our optimizer so keras recognizes
the names of common optimizers and loss
functions if you pass them as strings so
it saves time to do that if you only
want the default settings but now we're
professional machine learners and that
salary review is upcoming so we've got
our very own learning rate schedule and
we're going to do things properly so the
first thing we do is we import the
optimizer and then we initialize it with
the scheduler which is getting passed to
the learning rate argument of that
optimizer
now we compile the model with this new
optimizer and again whatever loss
function you want so this is going to be
sparse categorical cross entropy if
you're following along from the fine
tuning video
and then we're ready to go we now we
have a high performance model ready for
training all that remains is to fit the
model just like we did before
remember because we compiled the model
with the new optimizer and the new
learning rate schedule we actually don't
need to change anything at all when we
call fit we just call it again with
exactly the same command as before but
now we get beautiful training with a
nice smooth learning rate decay starting
from a good value and decaying down to
zero